It's important to find out the constraints as soon as possible, but there's no
reason to rush forward and die without a plan.You're the
one who said I'm disappointing, right?
[Music] I
don't remember.Well,
as long as the parties are in agreement,
cooperation is also a problem.  No, right?
[Music] I haven't
said we'll team up yet.
Can I trust a kunoichi?
Stop it! I'm not a child to trust you. You
can betray me at any time.
Even if I find the drug, only one person will be innocent. And we'll
take advantage of each other until the very last moment.  Are you saying that?
Or are you just scared of me? That's
surprising. It
's a waste of time to help girls when you ask for help.